MISSING JOSH BAILEY.
ISLANDERS GET THE PUCK OFF
OFFENSIVELY. TOO,
EITHER INDE SKIPS
THROUGH FOX.
DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH JUICE FOR AY
>> Brendan: FANS LIVING IN
HARMONY SO FAR
ZIBANEJAD.
>> Butch: HE WINS IT.
>> Brendan: TROUBA KEEPS IT IN
WITH HIS SKATES.
UNCHARACTERISTIC THREE
SHORTHANDED GOALS.
>> Butch: THAT WAS ALMOST -- I
WAS GOING TO SAY --
>> Brendan: IT'S A BARZAL.
TROUBA'S GOING IN ALL ALONE.
ALTHOUGH I LIKE THE PERCENTAGES
FOR THE G TIMES PEOPLE ARE
JUMPING AND YOU GET CAUGHT IN A.
DROP THE
RIGHT SIDE STROME, GOAL LINE,
SCORE.
CHRIS KREIDERER THE PUCK ALL TH.
WATCHING HIS DROP DOWN.
AND A NICE LITTLET HIT THE ICE.
>> Butch: MIDSECTION, SHESTERKIN
HAD A GOOD, LONG LOOK AT IT.AN
WAHLSTROM SIDESTEPS A A TROUBLES
GOT NOWHERE TO GOGOODROW FOR RY
IN FRONT IS LaDUE.
NO, ROONEY GGEAU STEPS, SHOOTS,.
EVENTUALLY COMES
STRAHM COMING OUT OF THE  TURNOH
>> Brendan: THIS HAS INTENSE
SEASON, SANDY BLAIS IS DONE FOR
THE RANGERSING.
ANDREOFF BOTH THERE, THE
ISLANDERS ARE OFF THE BOARD
WITHIN ONE.
>> Butch: THEY PICK THE PICK UP
PUCK.
>> Brendan: HE PLAYED 12 NHLOUR.
THERE'S NO ANGLE THERE.
LOOK WHERE HE IS RIGHT NOW.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE OUT THERE.
>> Brendan: SOMEONE,
DON'T LET
HAD SIX AGAINST THEAS NOT BEEN
VERY SHARP.
SLOW TO REACT, REALLY.